long-term potentiation is a persistent
increase in the synaptic strength
following a high frequency stimulus so
this is a synapse if we stimulate the
synapse we would get some response now
if there is a 100 Hearts tetonic
stimulation for several times then after
the same stimulation we would get an
augmented response this augmentation in
the synaptic response is known as
synaptic potentiation and it's thought
to come from synaptic strengthening so
nmd receptor is involved underlying ltp
this is the ltp trace if nmd receptor is
blocked ltp is
abolished this is how a normal synapse
look like and this is how a potentiated
synapse look like which is much bigger
and stronger scientists think long-term
potentiation is a key mechanism by which
memories are stored in human brain watch
the full video to know more